>> So Spencer, now that we went through
this process and, I'd just like to hear
whether you enjoyed it, whether you think it
was useful. What are your thoughts?
>> Well, ti was very interesting. I not only
learned something about computers and about how you design information systems
in UML, but I, it was interesting. I also learned something
interesting about the library. And things that, that I knew but
I never really, explicitly written down.
>> Uh-huh.
>> Came up during the course of doing this. And I think I now
much better understand what this information system that you're
going to build for us, is really all about.
>> Okay, well, I mean, I'm very happy that you say
that, because I really believe that, you know, doing this kind
of analysis and design exercises really helps you figuring out whether
there's any issues with the requirements. So for example, you can find
out whether there's any missing information, or maybe conflicting
information. And I think that's exactly what happened today.
So I'm very glad to hear that it worked for you. That you enjoyed it. I hope you
enjoyed it as well. And I strongly encourage you
to do this kind of exercises for different kinds
of systems. So as you can become more familiar
with analysis and design techniques. So, any final thoughts?
>> I look forward to receiving your delivered software.
>> All right. Will do.